Okay.
As you may remember,
way back before the uh,
exam,
we'd started looking at how things really happened,
how people were able to figure out about bonds and how atoms were arranged and
molecules reacted before.
There were the powerful techniques that we developed mostly in the last 25 or 30
years as far as their practical application in organic chemistry.
But how they found these out before that time,
and it started with what we call the chemical revolution,
which was launched by Lavoie ca with this book in 1789 the same year as the
French revolution,
the elementary treatise of chemistry,
which you remember,
he started work on just because he was interested in improving nomenclature,
but found that there was a such a tight coupling between nomenclature and the
science that that is the fact and the theory that he couldn't improve any one of
them without improving the others.
So we saw last time that,
that he,
uh,
that he developed a,
that in the process of developing a new nomenclature,
he also developed instruments so that he could weigh gasses because weighing
turns out to be such an important feature in all of 19th century chemistry,
no doubt the most important single technique.
But he also could measure heat,
which didn't have any weight for that.
He developed a calorimeter together with Laplas and we saw how that worked by,
by melting ice.
So now we're going to look at some of the other developments from this book in
particular,
the idea of oxidation by know that there's no doubt that the most important
element for Lavoie Oza was oxygen because of its key role in his chemistry,
so that all other elements were called bases or radicals,
right.
And they could react with oxygen to become new things.
There were several degrees of oxidation as shown in this table from the English
translation of his book.
So first you'd get an oxide oxides of all the elements that are listed in the
first table.
For example,
a hydrogen,
when oxidized would give water.
That's the second row.
But the first row is caloric.
This was sort of a stretch at least it seems so from our perspective that
caloric heat,
when it gets oxidized yields oxygen,
gas.
But then there were further degrees of oxidation if you reacted,
uh,
with more oxygen.
So there was second degree of oxidation according to his theory was to give an
acid that he,
that the suffix was to be systematically,
oh u.
So us and those names we use now like cupressus ferrous come directly from this
work of Lavoie Zaa.
So that's the lower oxidation state of an acid,
right?
So you have for example,
nitrous acid,
carbonic acid,
sulfuric acid,
phos for us acid,
he said,
and then you have a still higher degree of oxidation.
The third degree,
which is the [inaudible] acid.
So you have nitric acid,
carbonic acid,
sulfuric acid,
and notice that many of these were not known and many of them still are not
known because the theory wasn't exactly right.
For example,
carbon carbon,
us acid was not known at that time.
You see in the second entry in the second row,
second column.
Okay.
And then there was still a fourth degree of oxidation,
which he called the oxygenated Eric acid.
He didn't use the per oxy acid as we would often use nowadays,
but he used,
for example,
oxygenated nitric acid,
which was unknown.
Oxygenated carbonic acid was unknown.
Same for sulfuric or phosphoric and oxidated oxygenated muriatic acid was diff.
Logistic used to be called [inaudible] logistics,
hated marine acid,
but he has a more systematic name showing its degree of oxidation.
So these us and it Canadians that we still use come directly from Lavoie Z.
Uh,
and probably the,
uh,
the next most important,
a tool he developed was one for doing elemental analysis.
You remember,
you could do proximate analysis,
what other compounds are present in the substance you're studying?
Or You could do ultimate analysis and find out how much of the elements.
Uh,
there was an each,
and this was how to do elemental analysis of an organic oil.
So it has carbon,
hydrogen,
oxygen in it.
Okay.
So this big a upside down barrel inside another barrel with water in it is how
he got air for the burning because the upside down a barrel would be lowered
into the water,
which would create pressure and the oxygen that's trapped inside it would then
flow out through the pipe you see coming from the tank through a dryer and and
into this big,
uh,
big vertical cylinder where the combustion takes place fed by a,
an oil supply,
which,
uh,
is siphoned in as,
as needed.
Uh,
so there's a lamp inside burning the oil with the air and the vapors generated
by the combustion come up and out the tube to the right.
So there's the lamp,
the gas has come out and water gets condensed in the spiral tube in here and
drips down and gets collected in the jar that you see.
And the part that doesn't condense and get collected into the jar gets absorbed
in that horizontal tube that has calcium chloride drying agent in it.
So at the end of the,
of the experiment you weigh how much water there is in the jar and how much the
calcium chloride is increased in weight and that tells you how much water there
was.
And what does that tell you about the compound?
How much,
what,
what element is being measured in the oil by May,
my way in the water it's measuring the hydrogen,
so he had to know what percent by weight,
water is of hydrogen.
Then if he measured the water that came from combustion,
he measured how much hydrogen there was in the oil sample that was being burned.
And then the,
the gas is continued to go through lime,
water,
calcium hydroxide,
so that would absorb a CO2 as calcium carbonate.
So those would include increase in mass and he had two of them.
So whatever got through the first one would hopefully be collected in the next
one.
And then there's another drawing tube on further from that because these
solutions,
as you pass gas over them,
they lose a little bit of their water right.
So they'd be losing weight as well as gaining weight from the CEO to that's
being absorbed,
right.
But the law,
but that water that's lost is reabsorbed in that final tube.
So you weigh in at the end and now you have,
you've corrected for whatever loss of water there was from the bulbs.
And now you know what weight of CO2 and if you know what fraction of Co two is
carbon and there's a homework problem for Friday that you can look at.
You can work in groups on that.
Uh,
that shows you how he knew how much,
uh,
what weight percentage of CO2 was carbon.
So having that measured,
how much,
how much co two.
He knew how much carbon there was the oil.
So we measured the hydrogen,
he measured the carbon.
So that's fine if it's a hydrocarbon oil.
How about if there was oxygen in the oil notice?
He's adding all kinds of oxygen from the air.
So how's he going to know how much oxygen there was?
If it was an alcohol or something that he was burning?
Sam
can't hear you.
It's the leftovers.
You see how much oil got burned,
how much carbon,
how much hydrogen.
And you assume there's nothing else there except oxygen.
So you get oxygen by difference and that's the way oxygen is almost always
measured is by difference,
right?
So you assume and you have to be sure there are no other elements there.
If you want that to be true,
obviously.
Okay.
So this was a big operation and it took,
you know,
somebody to control the air supply to make sure it was constant.
Notice incidentally,
there's a tea here.
So there was another one of these things,
but over here and another one of these double barrels,
right?
Why?
Ah,
so when you,
when you run out of air in one,
you switch to the valve and take it from the other one,
then you can go back to the first one.
So you have an infinite supply of air,
plenty to burn the oil,
right?
But you need someone to control that and you need someone else to make sure the
lamp stays lit,
that it gets the proper amount of oil siphoned in and the air flow is right.
You need someone else in the COO to collectors,
you just blow gas over the surface.
Right?
So it's got little key on the top and a hook that goes down in somebody.
Somebody has to be standing there doing this to keep it stirred.
Right.
So that's true.
So it takes at least three or four people to run this thing.
Right.
And it costs a lot of money to build.
So no one else built one.
In fact,
it's not absolutely certain that Lavoie z a ever used this,
although it exists.
Right.
Because he was busy with other things having to do with the French revolution by
the time this came along.
But this was big science.
Right.
And he was very wealthy,
so he was able to do this kind of thing.
But he showed in this diagram exactly how it could be done.
So it was no secret,
not like the,
not like what the alchemists did was our questionnaire.
No.
Yeah,
they did.
They may measure the amount of air that into it.
Uh,
no.
Like I don't think so because there wasn't any purpose.
You didn't care how much air you put in because all,
most of the air just flowed right on through.
It was never collected,
right?
It just carried the other gasses along where the water and the co two would be
collected.
What it is
you,
the
content of the air.
Like they could just measure
how much oxygen to get the oxygen conceivably,
but that was never done.
It would've been very difficult to collect all that air and measure it
accurately.
Okay.
Now what if you have a substance that won't burn cleanly?
So you can't measure these gasses.
Notice incidentally the role of gases and understand things in it because they
provide easy separation,
right?
And then since he was able to weigh gas once,
then he knows the gas density.
So now all you have to do from then on in principle is measure the volume of
gas.
And you know how much stuff there was.
So gas has played a really key role through all this,
but suppose you had a substance that wouldn't burn,
that you couldn't convert to steam and Co two what do you do then?
For example,
grape sugar.
So here's chapter 13 where he talks about the lawsuit,
the Hiza,
the grape sugar,
which will,
which will char,
it won't burn cleanly.
So what do you do well is he says up at the top there to the mall affect come
also fellow VA,
everyone knows how to make wine,
cider and mead,
right?
So can you see what he's gonna do?
So here's the device for that one,
which is in many ways sort of similar,
but you don't need an air.
So you don't put the area in what you have as a big a flask at the beginning,
which has sugar,
yeast and water,
right?
So the yeast ferments the sugar and changes it into,
uh,
into co two.
So you have it foams up.
If you've ever seen something for many,
they say you have to have something that catches the foam so it won't get into
your device.
And then you have something that will absorb water.
Now the water is not just,
it's not like the previous one where,
where the water is all formed by thing.
Cause you've got a whole bunch of water there at the beginning.
Right?
So that's not what you're trying to measure.
What you're trying to measure is how much carbon,
how much co two there is in the grape sugar.
So you have these sodium sodium hydroxide solutions,
the base that will absorb the co two as,
as carbonates are you weigh those before and after.
And the excess gas,
if there's another gas being evolved,
will uh,
collect over the mercury in the Fart tube here so he could measure the CEO,
the carbon by in sugar,
by converting it completely to CO2 through fermentation.
In speaking of a fermentation here,
he says it furnishes of means of analyzing sugar.
Uh,
so oxidation failed with air,
even with oxygen or sulfuric acid or mercuric oxide.
You couldn't get clean combustion of sugar.
You got charring instead.
But as he says here,
this is the most interesting thing about his,
his,
uh,
his treatment of the data.
He said,
I could consider the materials subjected to fermentation and the products of
fermentation as an Algebraic equation having to do with weights.
And what's it,
can you see,
what is assumptions going to be here,
Sam?
The same weights on both side.
Conservation of mass.
This is assumption.
Okay.
So he can make an equation that the weight on the right and the weight on the
left will be the same.
Okay,
so an Algebraic equation and by in turn,
supposing each of the elements of the equation to be unknown,
I can derive a value and thus correct experiment by calculation and calculation
by experiment.
So what does he mean by that?
So if you have this equation to a certain amount of sugar and a certain amount
of oxygen gives a certain amount of CO2 for example.
Right?
So the weight's on the two sides should be the same.
He doesn't know one of them.
Right?
But,
but if he knows all the others and it's an Algebraic equation,
he can then solve for that one.
So he says,
here,
I can derive a value in this.
Correct.
Experiment by calculation.
Have you ever heard of that being done?
Likely.
When somebody,
would you do that in lab?
Correct.
Experiment.
You suppose there might be any nefarious people who would correct their
experiments by calculation after finishing the lab?
I can't imagine that would happen.
Okay.
But labanzia was up front,
right?
And he was even one might say bragging about it,
that he has this algebraic equation so we can correct his experiments,
right?
I've often profited from this way of correcting the preliminary results of my
experiments.
No one told him that that's not the way science works,
right?
That the experiments are the things you have to have to adjust the theory
to deal with the experiments.
Okay.
So he was,
remember he was,
he was the,
uh,
the,
the treasurer for the firm that,
that collected taxes for the French crown,
right?
So he was accustomed to bookkeeping and everything had to balance right down to
the SU,
right?
So the same thing,
he applied to chemistry.
So he,
so table one here is the materials of fermentation.
He put in a certain amount of water,
400 pounds,
certain amount of sugar or a hundred pounds a yeast.
Now he knew that the yeast was wet.
So there was a certain amount of water.
He tip 10 pounds of yeast,
but he knew by analysis,
uh,
by proximate analysis,
right?
Not how much am I not what the elements are.
But what the substances are there,
there that in 10 pounds of,
of uh,
yeast,
wet yeast,
you'd have seven pounds,
three ounces,
six grow and 44 grains.
Uh,
turns out that a grow is a 70 seconds of a grain and a and eight grow make an
ounce.
So,
so it's a grow is in which is 28.35 grams.
So if you want,
you can work through all this.
Do you think he had analyzed things that accurately
that he knew right down to the,
to the,
uh,
to the grow,
how much there was in there?
No,
he couldn't,
there's no way he could have known that.
But things had to balance.
Right.
So he made an approximate thing and then he carried it out to 18 decimal points
the way you do on a calculator.
Right.
Okay.
So he didn't know about significant figures yet either.
So then in Table Two,
he figures in that much in that much water sugar,
yeast.
How much is there of in each one,
how much is in water,
how much is hydrogen and how much is oxygen?
So he knows that.
So now he knows down to hundreds of grow how much of each of those elements
there are in the,
in the 400 pounds of water he's using.
Incidentally,
he never used 400 pounds of water.
He just rounded these numbers up or multiplied his number,
scaled them up to be that big.
He used large quantities but not that large.
Okay.
So if you had a hundred pounds of sugar,
you'd have certain amount of hydrogen,
oxygen and charcoal that is carbon.
And if you had a certain amount of the dry yeast,
you'd have that.
And then he makes still a third table where he rearranges it.
So he pulls the elements altogether.
So in the starting material,
how much hydrogen?
Oxygen.
Carbon.
Okay.
So he's got a 411 pounds,
12 ounces,
six grow,
1.3599999999999999 grains of oxygen in our brains and grow.
Got It.
Oh,
growing grains.
Okay.
Right.
That much oxygen and some amount of hydrogen and charcoal and a certain amount
of nitrogen that's in the yeast because that's an,
he knew that was there.
Okay.
Uh,
which is just a small weight all together.
Cause there's not much east and in all 510 pounds.
Exactly right.
So his balance sheet was just like what a banker would want.
Okay.
And now he does,
he looks at the products and he has a certain amount of co two that he collected
that's carbonic acid and he knows how much oxygen charcoal there is that certain
amount of water,
a certain amount of alcohol if if dry.
So he had to collect the alcohol and say how,
how much alcohol and how much water was in it,
but how much a CD Casad,
how much residual sugar that had fermented and how much dry yeast there was at
the end.
And he added them all together.
And by God there was 510 pounds,
zero ounces,
zero bro and zero grains.
Right.
Qed.
Okay.
And then he recapitulated that according to how much oxygen,
how much charcoal and how much hydrogen in that.
Once again,
it balances out.
Absolutely.
Precisely.
Okay.
So we recapitulates it that way and this is how he would do some of these
things.
Okay.
So this is a description of experiment on page 88 to 92 of the Tata Eddie
Monteiro.
Okay,
so he's got a fire burning here and a glass tube that runs through the middle of
the charcoal that's burning,
right?
And he's got a flask,
a cemented to it on the right,
which is over a burner.
And in the tube he puts 28 grains of carbon that,
not pieces,
but a weight of 22 grades.
We saw what a grain was last time.
That turns out to be 1.38 grams of carbon.
He's got inside the tube.
Okay,
and now do you think the carbon will evaporate?
Incidentally,
if you put it in flight?
You know how,
how do you know it won't evaporate?
Where do you get carpet?
What did he call it?
He called the charcoal.
You get charcoal in a fly in,
right?
So with birding,
without enough oxygen.
So obviously it's not going to evaporate,
it's just going to sit there.
Okay?
So in,
in the flask a there,
he puts water.
So there's water in it and then he lights the fire underneath and the water
begins to boil and distills through the tube and collects over here in age.
All right.
Okay.
What did you notice?
What happened in the process?
Let me back up and do it again.
What happened?
The charcoal went away.
Well,
let's see what he found.
So the 28 grades of carbon was gone,
right.
And in the end he got the water that he'd put in at the start,
but not all the water.
It was 85.7 grains short.
So the,
all the carbon in some of the water is gone.
Where did it go?
Well it went out the two,
so out the tube he said came 144 cubic inches.
And because he knows the density,
he knows how much weight that is.
A hundred grains exactly.
Of Carbonic gas co two we would call it c o two and 380 cubic inches of
flammable gas.
So one of them would be collected by lime water,
the carbonic gas and the other one would go right on through.
What do you suppose flammable gas is?
Hydrogen.
So the oxygen went to the carbon and the hydrogen became elemental hydrogen in
this process.
Okay,
now look at this.
This is what's neat.
So you've got a hundred gram,
100 grains probably of of carbonic gas and 13.7 grains of Hydro Jen.
The stuff that gives water when you burn it according to him,
right?
Which is right,
which is correct.
And what do you notice
quantitatively
exactly that,
right down to the tenths of of grains.
Okay?
Now,
if you recalculate by modern theory,
how much gas you should get from 28 grains of carbon doing this,
you should get a 157 cubic inches and 313 cubic inches.
Instead of 144 three 80 you should get 103 grains of carbonic gas and 9.4 grains
of flammable gas.
So his experiments weren't perfect,
right?
Which is not surprising and there's no shame in that.
But what would we now say he did wrong?
He adjusted his results that fit his theory.
Hey,
but this was early days.
He thought that he actually said on page 92,
I have thought it best to correct by calculation and to present the experiment
in all its simplicity.
Now what's wrong with presenting experiment in all its simplicity.
You lose anything that's new.
Anything that you might have discovered in the experiment.
Okay.
But,
but he was discovering a lot of stuff so we'll forgive him that.
Okay.
He was certainly a great scientist.
So what were his contributions?
Clarity above all right.
This idea of facts and ideas and words having to go together and improve
together and have the facts he worked on.
There were these,
the apparatus I showed and others as well.
Important,
important thing was quantitative,
using numbers which people hadn't used before at not nearly as effectively.
At least concentrating on making things balance,
using mass as the criteria for how much stuff you have,
but also in the case of,
of uh,
of gasses volume,
but measuring the density so that you can relate volume to mass,
which is the fundamental quantity.
Uh,
he found some new substances,
although that wasn't much of a contribution on his part.
Other people like Shayla before him had discovered lots and lots of new pure
substances that wasn't [inaudible] strong suit and reactions.
And the,
uh,
then with respect to ideas,
the idea of what an element is that it's not some Playtonic ideal,
but it only means as far as we've so far been able to go and analyze in things
and breaking them down.
And if we can't break them down further,
we'll assume for the time being that they are elements.
But it may be that they won't be in the long run.
The idea of conservation of mass,
of course,
is key oxidation as the organizing principle.
Uh,
the idea of a radical than an element is the base of something and that it can
become an acid through oxidation.
And the idea of salts be,
uh,
from,
from mixing of,
of,
uh,
elements and with respect to words,
the idea that names should be meaningful in particular the names for element's,
oxidation states.
So he developed these,
these uh,
suffixes,
us,
[inaudible] I eight and eight are all due to Lovaza and the idea of assault
composition,
the way of naming them that,
uh,
sodium hydroxide for example,
or sodium chloride or,
or chlorate or chlorite,
which are different degrees of oxidation of the,
of the element.
Okay.
But like everyone who would follow and everyone before and everyone nowadays,
he was plagued by lack of imagination,
right?
That's always the short suit of a,
everyone who's in science are probably in anything.
Uh,
he said,
Kevin at the end of this preface that we've talked about,
chemistry is president progress,
however,
is so rapid and the facts under modern doctrine have assumed so happy and
arrangement that we have ground to hope even in our own times to see it approach
near to the highest state of perfection of which it is susceptible,
right?
So people always think that,
that,
that there are a few things that you can see you have to do to fill in little
chunks here and there,
but otherwise we've got it now.
Right?
This is certainly what a lot of people tended to think about human geno.
Once you know what the human genome is,
then all diseases are solved.
Everything else,
right.
It's never been true.
And it almost certainly is not true now.
And it certainly wasn't true in his time.
He said,
even in our own times,
he wrote this in 1789 and in 1794 he was Ghia team,
so he shouldn't certainly didn't happen in his own time.
Uh,
the,
the judge co-fund hall is reported to have said all the perhaps apocryphally
that the Republican has no need of geniuses.
And in fact,
all his equipment was seized for the people,
including his 80 pounds of mercury that he carried around in this thing to
measure gasses.
That madness lasted only a couple of years,
maybe not even that long.
And his widow recovered the equipment and it currently is in the museum days
after they meet ta and in Paris.
I've never seen it,
but a number of students from the class have sent me postcards when they've gone
to see it.
Okay.
And La Garage.
The guy that helped him build the calorimeter,
uh,
wrote it,
took them only an instant to make this head to fall.
But a 100 years may not suffice to reproduce one like it.
So what we're going to look at is what the heads in the next hundred years we're
able to accomplish.
So today we're going to do the first 20 year or 25 or 30 years after Lovaza Aa
to see where things went.
So we've looked at Boyle and his gas laws and Lavoie ca and now we're going to
go onto Dolton.
So here's John Dalton who lived up near the Lake district in England and it was
an amateur meteorologist.
So he was interested in keeping weather records and so on.
And in particular he was interested in why in the atmosphere,
if you take a collect air at the top of a mountain and down in the bottom of a
valley,
you get the same composition.
Why don't the heavier gasses sink and the lighter ones rise?
Good question.
Right?
Well,
people on the continent had proposed that different gases attract one another.
So they tend to stick and therefore stay mixed,
right?
But Dalton had a different idea,
and this is a picture he drew of,
of gasses.
The top is a up or uh,
or nitrogen in the bottom is hydrogen.
So he said the Adams of one kind or did not repel the Adams of another kind.
It's not,
well,
you'll see just a second.
Okay.
So the center is his symbol for the Adam nitrogen in that case,
and surrounding that,
this sort of Halo is the envelope that's heat associated with that particular
item.
So these rays come out and if the rays meet one another between adjacent atoms
in the gas,
then they repel one another according to Dalton's theory.
But if they don't match as in hydrogen and nitrogen,
then they don't repel one another,
right?
So Adams of the same element can to stay apart.
But the Adams of the other element are completely free to be inside there.
They knew that the pressure went down as you went up.
That was no question.
Right?
But why?
Why don't they stratify?
It's because the different elements don't repel one another.
So he substituted homo repulsion that the same atoms repel one another for what
the Europeans used as Hetero attraction.
Okay.
Obviously that turned out to be nonsense.
But,
uh,
Dalton developed three principles in terms of these atoms that he had that he
had,
uh,
started using for this purpose of something about the atmosphere.
These principles have come to be known as definite proportions,
equivalent proportions,
and multiple proportions.
So definite proportions is that pure compounds always have the same weight ratio
of their elements.
So you don't get a sample of,
uh,
of uh,
sugar here.
That's a certain percentage of carbon and hydrogen and a slightly different
percentage of carbon hydrogen here.
And he explains it by saying that these compounds are a given ratio of elements.
So you have that same ratio all the time when you have a particular compound.
Now,
equivalent proportions is a pretty simple idea,
but it looks complex.
Okay?
So suppose you have a certain weight of a reacts with a certain way to be okay
to form a,
B and a certain amount of a react with a certain amount of c to form a c.
But if it's the same amount of a,
then in some sense a certain that way to be and that weight of see are
equivalent to one another.
Okay.
Cause they react with the same way to a,
so they're equivalent.
But now suppose you have another compound d that also reacts with B parts of B
a reacted with be parts of B.
Right?
What does that tell you
about equivalence?
That means that a parts of Ey is equivalent to deep parts of d.
Okay.
So just for suppose a two grams of a re,
uh,
reacted with three grams of B and two grams of a reacted with eight grams of c,
that means three grams of B is equal to eight grams of c for purposes of
combining.
Okay.
And suppose,
uh,
1.5 grams of d also reacted with three grams of B,
then 1.5 grams of d is equal to one gram of A.
Okay.
Now what could you conclude?
What's the final line going to be?
What do you predict from this?
If you have these kinds of equivalents and equivalence between B and C and
equivalence between a
safe,
then you predict that if you react d and see what's going to happen,
what rate ratio will they be on?
D parts of d will react with c parts of see,
right?
Because the D is like the a in the beginning of the sea is like the be in the
beginning.
So deep parts of Asia react to seed parts to see that's what multiple
proportions is.
I'll show you an example.
Okay.
And finally,
multiple proportions if the same two elements formed,
several different compounds.
The weight ratios are related by simple factors,
and I'll show you an example of that.
So these are all things that Dalton at deuced as support for the idea that
things were made of atoms,
fundamental units.
Now definite proportions do this,
this the same compound always have the same ratio of the elements in in it.
The,
the,
the French school was divided on this question,
belittle a said no.
And Proust said wait,
because he said they're metal alloys or natural organic materials that that vary
in their analysis.
Right.
Okay.
And Preuss said,
we write and that defined what chemistry was,
that chemists then began to deal only with things that obeyed this law of
multiple proportions.
They didn't deal in fundamental ways with alloys are with,
with a complicated big molecules that had really complicated formulas or
couldn't be separated as mixtures and therefore got different analysis at
different times.
They assume that anything that was pure had this obeyed the law of definite
proportions.
So it was really more of a definition right,
than a law.
Okay.
Now,
multiple proportions.
So there were oxides of carbon.
You remember Lavoie Oza 1789 fine,
44% carbon,
56% oxygen and co two and there again there,
there are problems for you to work together to see how he did some of these
things.
So that's one of them,
I believe.
And then in 18 one carbonic acid as it was called,
was analyzed and found to be 28 grams of carbon to 72 to 72 grams of oxygen.
Okay.
Or in the case of op nitrogen,
there were several oxides that had these ratios all as analyzed in 1810 right
now,
uh,
you can look at their weight ratios if you want to oxygen to carbon ratio in the
first one is 1.27 the others 2.57 or you can look in the oxides of nitrogen and
they're 0.58 1.27 2.39 right now.
What do you notice about these?
You'll learn anything from this.
Okay.
That'd be these guys got these results and sat down and scratched their heads.
What did they come up with?
Anything profound?
Any relationships among these numbers that you can see?
Are they just sort of random numbers?
Yeah.
Nick,
can you speak up a little pellets at 1.27 1.27 is very close to half of 2.5 so
it's not exact,
but there's going to be experimental error,
right?
It's about one to two.
It's actually 2.02 and if you look in the case of nitrogen,
it's one to two to four right?
It's actually 2.19 and 4.12 so as always,
when people develop things experimentally and,
and,
and observe and observe regularities,
there's the question of what,
what's,
what's real and what's just experimental error?
And you have no way of knowing at the beginning we'd have a way of knowing now,
cause we know what the,
what the true waits are.
So they're integral values consistent with simple atomic ratios.
So now we know what the percent errors were in these things.
Okay.
That,
that uh,
that the ratio or the air was about 5% or 4% off for what it should have been.
And then oxygen,
nitrogen one is minus 2% others are plus 11% so within roughly 5% or so,
they were doing pretty good job of the analysis,
but they were able to see through to this law of multiple proportions think,
and that's what you would expect if,
if these things were made up of identical molecules with simple ratios of
numbers of Adams in them.
So this tended to support Dalton's ideas of Adams.
Okay.
So we've looked at Lavoie,
ca and now we're on further into elemental analysis doing accurate elemental
analysis and the idea of Adams and dualism.
And we'll see what that is right away.
And to do that,
we're going to focus on Brett's alias,
but also talk about gay Lou sock.
Okay,
so there,
there's fair day who we've talked about already are salient and Galas sock and
also Davey in England.
Okay.
So here's [inaudible] is in Sweden more than 1779 is you notice on the previous
slide,
all those guys were born within a year,
1778 1779 and another guy that was born at the same time didn't make it to the
list,
but his statue is right below who's Benjamin Selman.
He was exactly the same time.
Okay?
So here's a bit salients who lived to be almost 70 years old and did an awful
lot of stuff.
So he was very good at analysis,
both of organic substances and of minerals.
He in,
in a period of six years,
he accurately analyze 2000 compounds for their elements.
He,
he developed really good atomic weights.
Remember we just saw that these previous ones were off by as much as 10,
10,
or 11%,
but he got very good ones for 50 different elements.
Okay.
He studied electrolysis,
which we will see and use that to develop the theory of dualism and how
understanding reactions as double d compositions.
And we'll certainly see what that is.
And he did a lot of teaching and writing.
He was the most respected,
uh,
chemist worldwide.
Uh,
he'd chosen his picture.
Remember what these people got their pictures painted.
They always chose some emblem to put in.
And he chose his textbooks that he wrote in 18,
three.
But he was a very important editor and summarizer of the year's progress in
chemistry every year.
Uh,
and he developed the notation that we still use for composition.
So you'll see that,
okay.
Notation for composition.
We're going to look at its evolution from alchemy through Dalton to parts alias,
which is what we use almost exactly.
Okay.
So in 1774,
this is a table printed in Sweden,
have symbols for,
uh,
four elements and compounds.
And you'll see,
for example,
here is vitriol.
Copree or vitriol chip.
Uh,
[inaudible] you know what about Q three?
That's the symbol there of copper,
right?
So what,
why would they call it?
Why would it have been called Cerulean?
And you see any word that's related to that?
What's the rule?
The other about it
that's up here.
That's not it.
This is it.
Surillian right?
Like the sky.
Okay.
Uh,
or iron.
There's the alchemical symbol of iron ore and vitriol mean sulfate,
right?
Or Mercury sulfate.
Okay.
Led.
So these are the chemical symbols.
No notice particularly nitro,
him at the top.
That's comes from nitrates.
Okay?
And we'll focus on that and see that.
That's exactly the same symbol that Dolton used for nitrogen.
So he derived his symbols for Adams from the alchemical symbols,
at least many of them,
not all of them.
Here are some others.
And here are the symbols that Brett's alias used for the same elements,
which you see are the ones we use now.
Okay?
So notice as you did,
so there are al chemical symbols at the beginning for Dalton as you went across.
But in the next row,
once you get to iron,
which is Effie in Brasilia is,
can you see what it is?
It's a little hard to read at this resolution.
It's a little circle with a letter inside.
What's the letter for iron?
Can you say it?
It's in the middle of the second row.
It's an eye.
Sorry.
It's not such good resolution.
And the next one is z and then c and then l,
Y,
Z,
Zake.
See
Copper,
hell led and so on.
Okay.
Now in the now below that are binary symbol.
So you put two elements together like h with O,
h within and with O,
h with c,
O with see.
Now here's Dalton's logic about these symbols.
He said,
oops,
sorry.
He says when only one combination of two bodies can be obtained,
it must be presumed to be a binary one.
That is,
if you get only one compound,
it must be one atom of one and one atom of the other.
Right?
So what would water be?
H O or his circle with a dot of the circle.
Right.
Unless some other cause appear to the contrary.
That would show you that that's not what you should assume.
Okay?
The next row,
the ternary ones and two O and o,
two zero two ch two.
And what he said about that is when two combinations are observed of the same
elements,
then they must be presumed to be a binary and a ternary.
So you'd have eno and an o two.
What if there are three combinations of the same elements that are you of
compounds?
You see what he's going to observe,
but he's going to suppose
when three of visionary and the other two turnery.
Okay?
Okay.
And how about if there for
when for one binary to turnery and one quaternary.
Okay,
so he's laying down rules of logic for what the way atoms must behave.
And it turns out,
as we know,
Adams have different ideas from Dalton's logic.
Nothing illogical about Dalton.
It's just wrong.
Okay?
And this is Brett's alias is notation for the same symbols that Dalton,
uh,
gave on the left.
But you notice they're completely recognizable to them except for one thing.
What's different
here was ours and here is presale.
He assists.
The only difference is he used superscripts instead of subscripts.
Okay.
And he decided to base the names on Latin so it would be international.
Whereas Dalton had used English and the formula's notice are not structural.
You might,
the bulk purchase aliases aren't,
they're just written in a line.
And the number of these could been assumed to be structural that you thought the
Adams were arranged that way.
I don't know that Dalton really had that idea,
but they have,
they sort of convey that idea.
But for sale is,
is don't,
they're just a list of the elements and the ratio by weight of Adams in them.
And he developed some more fancy abbreviations as well,
where,
for example,
these little dots above elements would show how much oxygen was associated with
it.
So that chromium [inaudible] Chroma [inaudible] was k with an o and chromium
with three o's.
Or down here he has some even fancier things.
Notice the superscripts to note the number of atoms,
uh,
and that this benzoic acid,
should be age 10 see 1403.
Now wait a second.
I carboxylic acid has how many oxygens
Carbox elite group to hear.
He's got three.
The reason is that he thought there was water in these acids,
so he did the heck out and to drive water out.
And what you actually were left with was the anhydrite.
So two assets that come together and lost water,
right?
So the formula should be see 10 see 1403 it's got c h 12 see 15 so not so far
off and he's got these neat symbols for as a CD.
Tartaric,
Cedric and so on.
Acid that those didn't catch on either.
But is it symbols for the elements did.
Now let's see what we got here.
One more topic.
Atomic weights and equivalents.
Okay.
These are Dalton's atomic weights that he used,
an 18 eight hydrogen one,
a carbon fee,
five nitrogen,
five oxygen seven and so on.
Now as of 2004 this is what they should have been.
What's wrong with Dalton?
Okay,
why is he so off so far?
For example,
in oxygen,
which should be 16 and he has seven
how can he be off that much?
True.
Get here.
Yeah.
What did he think?
Water was h oh,
we know it's h two o.
So the ratio is off by a factor of two,
right?
So all of these are off.
Most of these are off by a factor of two or three depending on what the true
formula we now know to be.
Okay.
But if you make that correction,
this is how,
what kind of errors he had in his atomic waste.
They were roughly 10% or so errors.
Right?
And the question in silicon chloride,
uh,
Thomas Thompson in Scotland thought it was s ICL,
Gmail and in Germany thought it was sic l two,
but Sally has thought it was sic l three and oddly in England thought it was sic
l four so you can have anything you wanted.
Right?
So which one is it?
How can you tell which one it is?
That's the problem.
Okay.
So this is when Galeas socked in.
Uh,
France gets into the act.
So in 18 four,
he,
uh,
and the physicist vo made a balloon,
a set to a height of 7,000 meters.
That's way the heck up there.
And in fact,
that was a record for the 50 years and they have a flat,
a big flask there.
Carrie,
why?
What do they want to do with our big flask?
Collect air at 7,000 meters and see if it's different.
Okay.
So they established it.
Atmospheric composition is invariant with altitude,
at least at the heights naked do.
But that's not the most important thing he did for our purpose.
What are the really important things that did was figure out how to oxidize
sugar,
how to burn sugar cleanly.
Remember,
Lavasa had to resort the fermentation,
but he found if the source of the oxidation with sodium chloride,
then you could hit them together and actually get it right and get water and co
two out of sugar.
So that was a very important practical contribution for,
for the present purposes.
He found that when you decompose water,
you get one to one volume of oxygen,
you get 1.9989 volumes of hydrogen.
And if you do the same thing with ammonia for a volume of nitrogen,
you get 3.08163 volumes of hydrogen in his experiments.
What did he conclude?
What was Galen socks?
Conclusion from this page?
What do you think he thought the values would have been if there was no
experimental error?
How much hydrogen,
what do you've got to and how much hydrogen we've gotten from nitrogen?
Three right.
They're very,
very close.
Just a few percent off.
Right.
And even closer in the case of water.
So what did he think?
Yeah,
he thought the number that the volume of a gas was proportional to the number of
atoms in it.
All right.
Whose name do you associate that with?
I have a god row,
but both of them did it independently.
And gala sock is the one whose data I'm showing here.
Okay.
So this was an alternative to Dalton's law.
Greatest simplicity.
Dalton said if there's only one combat must be one to one Hailu socks.
I'd look up the gas ratios and that turned out to be correct,
although it didn't get completely adopted for another 60 years.
That's really funny.
Okay.
That's enough for now.